I want to know what you would take.
Like if there was a fire raging through this home,
what are the absolute necessities that you would that are very dear to your
heart, that you like to?
How much time do you have much time? Oh,
I wake up right at first.
These two, because you're branding branding. No, no, no. It's not that,
it's just that because, um, I just liked them a lot. Okay.
They have sentimental value. They have sentimental belts.
I put the Gucci glasses on, you know what I mean?
Because I like them all to protect your eyes from the heat. Right.
I would have to get clothes on because I don't want to be on fire and running on
the street naked. Right. So I would get like my favorite pair of, um,
raw denims. I would get my favorite pair of golden goose shoes. Okay.
You know what I mean? I would probably take about 10 shirts.
Jules and I are still asleep at this point. Yeah.
But this is what I'm doing because I want to,
because I know what you're going to do. If I wake you up,
I have to do what you want to do. So I got to do my, take the animals.
I want to do that. I want to do that. I want to do it,
but let me just do forgot about the animal. Look it out angry. She is.
Are you angry?
No, go ahead. I want to know your soul, bury your soul,
who you really are.
First of all, shirts, golden goose. But also this is,
this is only going to take 40 seconds. Mind you okay.
Getting the shirt? I don't mean. Okay. All right. So you know,
I have another amendment then. Okay. So, um, okay. A minute pass.
I have my glasses on. I have all my clothes on, right? Yeah. And then sweetie,
and you'll wake up. I go fire,
question Mark. Right?
And then you'd wake Juul up. Right?
And then the next four minutes is the four months of hell. Yeah.
Is trying to wrangle the animals. The cats, the cats are the hardest. Right?
Um, I might leave one of them. I'm sorry. I have to, I have to.
No way. I already have a contingency plan for this stuff. Right. I practice.
I do. I run drills at home.
Yeah. She's like Ben still in the movie. The Royal Tenenbaums.
I am. That's exactly who I am actually. So like, I run like drills in my head.
Like I know exactly where their crates are, like where to corner Mike,
because cats get spooked. And when they, when they're spooked,
it doesn't matter if they love you, they'll just want to bolt. So I know.
Or all their crates are, I don't have one crate. I have three crates.
It does. But the cats in the dogs, all right. Now we have five minutes left.
What did we do? Okay.
Um, w I'm asking you, like,
what are things in this home that you absolutely value.
But the human beings.
Besides the human beings in the animals now.
Okay. Aside from that. Okay. Then I would probably go, um, you got four minutes.
I need my phone to my iPad. Okay, good, good. Yeah. Got to get that. Um,
I need my cigarettes. I'll talk to, I spoke to a day,
but I just need it because it's stressful. You can buy those. I don't have,
it doesn't matter. I need, you know what I mean? And if I can't find my lighter,
I'll just use the house, fire, stick a cigarette.
And then, um, that would get that. And then, um,
other than that, I think that's it. I'm out of the house. iPad. The humans,
the animals, right? My favorite clothes. My, yeah, my wallet.
That's it. And then I would be out of the house.
I have five minutes to spare and then I would call, what do you call? Nine one,
one or four? One, one. What do you do? You call for a call for one, one, right?
And go, you know what I mean? Hello, fire, fire,
fire, fire. Fire. Yeah. Oh, I'd probably wake up the neighbors.
How are you? How are you going to wake up our neighbor to the left, Joe? Yeah.
I would go knock on his door. Ah, not, probably not. Yeah. Probably not.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't wake up the neighbors. I,
they should know they should smell the smoke. Yeah. Yeah.
And then we would probably back the car out of the driveway a little bit. Yeah.
Get all everything in there.
And then we would go to like a four seasons or something or motel six, actually,
one thing I'm surprised she didn't take what I'm going to say.
I'm not going to say it's right next to you. Like there's no time to play,
dude. Right next to you.
Your father's ashes, babe.
There's no pretended to play on my PlayStation. I could go to the next day.
I can go to best buy and go buy a whole new set up to.
Be fair though. That's already been burned.
Yeah, just right here. I have no idea. I'm going to say this. Okay.
It's a real, this is a symbol.
I have no idea. What's in here. You're going to let him die twice.
You know what I mean? Is there
[inaudible] what if my dad didn't have a
[inaudible] yeah, yeah. Um, yeah, I probably, I w I do this,
wouldn't be in my forefront of my mind is he's already passed, you know, this,
to me, this is just a symbol, but, um, if I had time, maybe I would grab that,
you know, and maybe that tiger belly, neon sign.
I like that. Other than that, you know, it would be sad because you know,
a lot of these, um, all these little things,
that's on the walls and in these cupboards and all that stuff are things I've
collected over the years. And they have, you know, I'm not a hoarder,
but I have deep, um, you know,
emotional attachment to a lot of things because of memories and whatnot,
you know? Um, so it would be really a sad thing if we were in a fire. Yeah.
Yeah.
He does with, with me, like, I don't hold a single value.
Can you guys believe this nice single valuable piece of jewelry except for
Bobby's, um, drug ring.
Yeah. She has my drug ring. Where is it? I haven't it. Oh, I have it.
Yeah. I keep it nice and secure, but I'm just saying, besides that,
cause I don't wear fancy jewelry at all. Like I don't own a single,
like gold, anything. Nothing. Yep.